i thought we should take the time this
weekend to recapitulate the events
leading up to july 4th what led to the
declaration of independence
to understand what happened in the years
leading up to the american revolution
what we first have to understand
is that the british parliament saw a
major threat in the united states the
major threat was that the united states
was growing so quickly
that it was quite possible that
eventually the population of the united
states would outnumber the population
inside britain and when that happened
the center of power within great britain
would actually be across the water it
would actually be
in the united states because there'd be
more british citizens living in the
united states than they were living in
britain
and so they could not allow there to be
any sort of parliamentary representation
for elected officials by the members of
the
the american colonies it just wouldn't
have been a possibility
by the time of the revolution about 2.5
million american citizens who are not
slaves or native americans
living in the united states the
population of britain
at the time of the american revolution
was about 8 million that was that was
the total population of britain in 1775.
so the the fact that the united states
represented such a large
number was quite threatening right it
was the king making
power essentially or parliament making
power in the american colonies that
scared the
the jesus out of the british parliament
and so you see is from 1760s on
the beginning of the 1760s britain
continuously attempting to use the
colonies
as a sort of utter to to milk for
purposes
of adventures abroad because remember
the british empire the sun never set on
it
at the time at the time of the american
revolution the british empire spanned
basically uh across the world if you
look at a map of the british
empire in 1776 it's astonishing right it
covers
all of canada it covers a large swath of
africa
it covers australia it covers large
swaths of india
it moves into some of the asian islands
like it's it's enormous
and those are constituents right if
you're talking about places where the
british
had dominion you're talking about at
that point nearly half of africa
a large swath of the sub-indian
continent
and control of the seas essentially so
they had to get their money from
somewhere and the place they decided to
get their money was from these
american colonists so this the real
conflict of 1776
starts much earlier it starts circa
about 1764.
so 12 years in advance so it wasn't like
things just kind of blew up in 1775
there was a long train of abuses again
as mentioned in the declaration of
independence that led up to this so all
of this really starts in 1764 when
parliament passes what's called the
sugar act
the sugar act was designed to raise
revenue and so what they do is they
increase
tariffs on non-british goods that were
shipped to the colonies artificially
raising prices
on the colonists living in the united
states without their permission
is an indirect tax basically if you
wanted to get tea from india
and it wasn't a british good then it
would be taxed at a higher rate than the
british goods
and therefore you would either buy
british goods sending your money to
great britain
or you would have to spend more money
and pay a tax to great britain
because at this time capitalism was not
in vogue instead you had a sort of
mercantilist system
a state-sponsored charter system with
regard to capitalism
then parliament didn't stop there they
also issued a currency act which
prevented the americans from creating
their own currency
and trading amongst themselves without
using the british pound
and so colonists began boycotting
british goods they said okay well we're
just going to
consume domestically we're just not
going to buy anything from britain which
of course hurts
the british economy in pretty
significant ways not only that smuggling
becomes incredibly ripe because people
still want their goods at the price they
were paying before britain decided
to artificially raise the prices via
tariffs and taxation
in response in 1765 the british
government passes the quartering act
requiring the colonies to pay for their
own occupation
now the colonies are supposed to pay to
provide barracks and supplies to the
british troops and then they double down
even more in 1765 they passed the stamp
act
okay in which parliament issues a tax
you now have to pay the brits
on every newspaper almanac pamphlet
broadside on dice
on playing cards basically all the most
popular consumer items in the united
states are now going to be hit with a
british sales tax
how unpopular was this every stamp act
agent in the entire colonies
resigned before the effectuation of the
stamp act that's how unpopular it was
and congress passes a declaration of
rights and grievances
and this is when you start hearing the
claim no taxation without representation
right you can't tax us without our
permission
we don't even have constituency in
parliament in 1766 it looks like
parliament is going to back down and
maybe
some sort of of deal is going to be
reached
they repeal the stamp act but at the
same time they they want to save phase
so they pass what's called the
declaratory act
which says like we're not doing this
because of you guys we're just doing
this because we want to not because of
you guys
they also pass a new set of taxes on
glass lead paper
paint tea these are the town syntax
again the colonies basically said we're
gonna boycott all british products at
this point
and ignore the british government in
1768 the british start shipping
troops into boston in solidarity
virginia's house of burgesses condemns
the british actions against
massachusetts
and says that only virginia's governor
and legislature can tax the citizens
because the citizens are electing people
to the house of burgesses but they
haven't elected anybody in britain
again britain seems to want to back off
a little bit in 1770.
they walk back the town syntax except
for the tax on t
and in response it seems like things are
going to calm down the colonies then
release their boycotts
on the british imported goods and they
start buying british goods again but the
presence of british
troops in the colonies is still making
people very angry
the quartering act is still in place and
this results in 1770 in the boston
massacre
a famous situation in which british
troops who are quartered in boston
are out in public and a bunch of
colonists angry at their presence
begin rioting and chucking objects at
them and the british confused fire into
the crowd
killing some american citizens and their
lawyer in this case is john adams who
says these guys still deserve due
process
of law and uh they end up being
acquitted but this doesn't of course
solve any of the conflict it just
ratchets up the tensions in 1772
there's a case that is largely ignored
by sort of american history but is
pretty crucial actually
in which a bunch of men decided to
attack a british customs schooner a
boat for the customs officers near
providence rhode island
and the important thing here is that the
british government puts out a reward and
then when these guys are captured
instead of trying them in the united
states trial by jury
instead they decide to ship them back
overseas to britain because they are
afraid that there will be jury
nullification that an american jury
won't condemn these guys
so they ship them back to britain for
trial so now it's american citizens
don't even get trialed by jury of their
peers
instead they get shipped back to the
mother country where they know no one
and where the entire jury system is sort
of biased against them
in 1773 parliament again needing to
raise money they passed the tea
act here what they did is they reduced
the tax
on their own tea instead of raising
taxes on everybody else's tea
they just reduce taxes on british day
they subsidize british tea
and they undercut american tea or people
who are trying to ship in
foreign and this results in the boston
tea party in which americans say well
we're not going to allow you to do this
we're not going to allow you the
incentive
of boosting your own economy by
artificially lowering your price either
we're going to toss this tea overboard
in the boston tea party
in 1774 now britain is is getting
serious it looks like war starts to look
more inevitable
they passed the coercive act banning all
unloading or loading of ships in boston
harbor in response to the boston tea
party
they also give protection to all royal
officials allowing the transfer of every
single court case involving riot
suppression or revenue collection to
britain
so now this is the new rule if you riot
or if you
if you hurt a tax collector your trial
will not be held in the united states
the united states is too ungovernable
instead we're going to send you back to
britain
the quartering act is then broadened to
include not only
that the colonies are supposed to pay
for barracks now if the colonies won't
pay for barracks the quartering act says
that the british can simply confiscate a
home and quarter troops in private homes
the first continental congress is formed
in response and they create again
committees to boycott british goods you
can see how much of this is about
economics right but this is the whole
point
economics lies at the root of personal
individual rights whenever you see
people today
who talk about economics being
completely divorced from individualism
and rights understand that economics is
very much tied
to how we perceive our ownership of
property how we perceive rights that
pre-exist the government and what the
government's role is
in all of that economics is not just
quote unquote how we decide to structure
it is how we decide to treat people on
an individual level
so in response to all this british
troops begin to occupy
boston and fortify it and in response
the minimum are organized
in early 1775 parliament passes the new
england restraining act and now
war is pretty much on the horizon
british troops
are occupying and parliament bans trade
between the new england colonies
and anywhere except for great britain so
now they're basically saying we're going
to criminally prosecute you if you ship
your goods anywhere except for great
britain they're trying to cut off new
england from the rest of the united
states
is what's happening they've created
basically a protective trade wall
around new england and try to make them
dependent on the brits again
royal authorities also say that in order
to enforce this force may have to be
used
this all results in lexington and
concord which is really the start of the
revolutionary war
april 19th 1775 british troops move on
concord because they understand that
there is a an
ammunition repository there and they're
going to go there they're going to
remove the ammunition and and destroy it
paul revere and william dawes then go on
their famous ride to
activate the minutemen the minutemen
arrive at lexington the british
arrive at the same time almost by
accident firing gets started really
nobody knows who fired the first shot
the supposition now is that it was the
brits
they fired the americans at lexington
and then they proceeded to march
on concord at lexington several
americans fall but a bunch of british
are killed when they march on concord by
the militia
who are hiding out behind rocks and
trees and basically engaging in
guerrilla warfare
about a month later the second
continental congress is convened
and a month after that george washington
is named commander-in-chief
famously george washington wore his
military uniform to the second
continental congress because
he was the highest-ranking officer in
the british army who was serving in the
united states
at the time so he showed up in uniform
basically said i'm ready to go six days
later he took command in cambridge
massachusetts he can go visit the
exact site where he took command of the
british troops it's now a softball field
directly outside of harvard law school
actually
on june 12th general gage of britain
put martial law in effect in boston he
said anyone who helped the continental
army would be considered a traitor
americans in response fortified bunker
hill the british navy
sees this happening they open fire on
the hill americans resist
eventually they lose the hill but this
is the first major conflict of the
revolutionary war
it was basically 400 british troops and
a thousand american troops
in pitched battle now at this point
congress is still trying to figure out a
way out of this because conflict has now
been going on like violent armed
conflict has now been going on since
april
and it's been a full five years since
the boston massacre
congress is still trying to find a way
out without losing face
they declare their loyalty to the king
in the olive branch petition they say we
are loyal british subjects all we want
is our right
as british citizens and the king
declines john adams wrote at the time
that the olive branch petition
was basically like a last-gasp effort
and also an attempt to say to all of the
tories
in the in the colonies listen we've
tried here and they just won't let us
have peace
he wrote you'll see a strange
oscillation between love and hatred
between war and peace
preparations for war and negotiations
for peace we must have a petition of the
king
and a delicate proposal of negotiations
etc this negotiation i dread like death
but it must be proposed we can't avoid
it
discord and disunion would be the
certain effect of a resolute refusal to
petition and negotiate
so in other words you sort of have to
look conciliatory in order to unify the
country when the king rejects this thing
my hopes are that the ministry will be
afraid of negotiation as well as we and
therefore refuse it
if they agree to it we shall have the
occasion for all our wit vigilance and
virtue to avoid being deceived wheedled
threatened or bribed out of freedom if
we strenuously insist upon our liberties
as i hope and i'm pretty sure we shall
a negotiation will terminate in nothing
it will affect nothing so at this point
adams is saying revolution is coming at
the beginning of 1776
thomas payne releases common sense it
sells an astonishing 120 000 copies in
its first three months
again there are only 2.5 million
citizens of the colonies at the time
non-slave non-native american citizens
the british evacuate boston in early
1776 after the americans surround it
in may congress tells all of the
colonies to adopt their own
constitutions without regard
to the british crown's authority
remember all the states were originally
chartered by the british crown so that's
a revolutionary move
and now we get to the actual creation of
the declaration of independence and the
the declaration that we are going to be
a free and independent nation
june 7 1776 richard henry lee is a
delegate from virginia
he read a resolution before the
continental congress and it is adopted
quote that these united colonies are
and of right ought to be free and
independent states that they are
absolved from all allegiance to the
british
crown and that all political connection
between them and the state of great
britain is and ought to be
totally dissolved richard henry lee has
sort of an interesting history
originally he was supposed to be the guy
who wrote the declaration of
independence
he's sort of been a little bit forgotten
by history richard henry lee very famous
family obviously
his cousin lighthorse harry was general
during the revolutionary war you'll know
that his son
was uh robert e lee of course he becomes
another historic american figure
four days later there is a postponement
of consideration of the lee resolution
and whether it ought to be adopted and
the reason for this is partially a delay
tactic because many of the delegates
remember communications weren't
instantaneous at this point
many of the delegates had to go back
home and get permission from
their constituents from the the
congresses and houses of burgesses
and parliaments etc there had to be some
sort of delay so communications could
take place
in the meantime the committee of five is
appointed the committee of five is
john adams benjamin franklin thomas
jefferson robert livingston of new york
and roger sherman
of connecticut now as i say originally
richard
henry lee was supposed to write the
declaration he couldn't because he was
busy drafting the articles of
confederation he thought that
that would be overburdensome and also
his wife was seriously ill jefferson
wanted adams to write it
and here's what adams later wrote to a
friend he said jefferson proposed to me
to make the draft
i said i will not you should do it oh no
why will you not you ought to do it
i will not why reason's enough what can
be your reasons reasons first you're a
virginian
and a virginian ought to appear at the
head of this business reason second
i have obnoxious suspected and unpopular
you are very much otherwise reason third
you can write 10 times better than i can
well said jefferson if you are decided i
will do as well as i can
very well when you've drawn it up we'll
have a meeting robert livingston you
know
the kind of forgotten members of the of
the committee robert livingston
actually had himself a pretty stellar
career he eventually became ambassador
to france under jefferson
he negotiated the louisiana purchase
sherman was the only man who signed the
articles of association the declaration
of independence the articles of
confederation and the constitution
which is a pretty impressive record as
well
now when it came to the actual
declaration of independence there was
some
negotiation over the language of the
declaration of independence at the
beginning
of july most controversially there
originally was a section in the
declaration of independence
condemning the british empire for its
trafficking slaves the declaration of
independence said quote he has waged
cruel war against human nature itself
violating its most sacred rights of life
and liberty in the persons of a distant
people who never offended him
captivating and carrying them into
slavery in another hemisphere or to
incur miserable death in their
transportation neither
and the notion that the american
revolution was rooted in a desire to
preserve slavery is a lie
hey even the founders who held slaves
many of them
believed in the immorality of slavery
they were of divided mind
on the subject of best jefferson is an
excellent example of this
jefferson in the same document called
slavery by radical warfare he mentioned
the british made an offer in 1775 that
if they joined the british
army they would be freed and jefferson
tried to
say well you the british forced slavery
upon the colonies
and now you want to free the slaves to
fight against us and that's not okay
that originally was in the declaration
as well this section was removed
at the behest of both southern states
who wanted to preserve slavery and
northern states who felt guilt in having
participated in the slave trade
later jefferson would write in his
autobiography the clause reprobating the
enslaving the inhabitants of africa was
struck out in compliance to south
carolina and georgia
who had never attempted to restrain the
importation of slaves and who on the
contrary still wish to continue it
my northern brethren i also believe felt
a little tender under these sensors for
though their people had very few slaves
themselves they had been pretty
considerable carriers of them
to others so the question was would
there be a revolution or would there not
the language was removed same sort of
thing with the constitution
would there be a country or would there
not was the question and slavery
had to take a backseat to the eternal
detriment of the united states but that
was at the time an insoluble problem
on july 2nd 1776 the lee resolution was
adopted by 12 of the 13 colonies new
york abstained
after voting for independence the
congress made changes until july 4th
and then signed the declaration of
independence itself the adoption of the
lee resolution on july 2nd is it
is what adams thought would be historic
he thought that we'd all be celebrating
july 2 rather than july 4.
he wrote the second day of july 1776
will be the most memorable
ipoca in the history of the united
states he said i am apt to believe it
will be celebrated by succeeding
generations as the great anniversary
festival
it ought to be commemorated as the day
of deliverance by solemn acts of
devotion to god almighty it ought to be
solemnized with pomp and parade with
shows games sports guns bells bonfires
and illuminations from one end of this
continent to the other from this time
forward forevermore
you will think me transported with
enthusiasm but i am not i'm well aware
of the toil and blood and treasure that
it will cost us to maintain this
declaration and support and defend these
states
yet through all the gloom i can see the
rays of ravishing light and glory i can
see that the end is more than worth all
the means and the posterior will triumph
in that day's transaction even although
we should ruin which i trust in god we
shall not for a guy who said that he was
a poor writer uh adams uh was not
correct about that
so there's a lot worth celebrating there
you have sort of a a quick
history of the lead-up to the
revolutionary war a good thing to
remember on this independence day
i hope that you're having a wonderful
independence day weekend and just
remember
all the people who've come before you to
make that possible